[موسيقى]
يقع في منطقه البرتان بشمال الفرنسي خليج
موربي ارخبيل ذو كنوز كثيره يحتوي على
حوالي 40 جزيره الجمال والروعه اكبرها ليل
اومان يتم زيارتها مشيا على الاقدام
وبواسطه الدراجات الهوائيه او من خلال هذه
الحافله
الصغيره اغلق عليكم جيدا حتى لا
افقد تقطع يوميا 50 كيلومترا من خلال
حافلت لا لشيء الا لتساعد ركابها على
اكتشاف جزيره ذات مساحه 3 كيلومتر مربع
يعيش بها 600 ساكن على مدار
السنه سكان يلقبون بدي اووا
وليس لا نستطيع زيارتها مشيا ولا عبر
الدرجات طمئنا نكتشفها من خلال الكثير من
الشروحات ومعرفه تاريخها ورؤيه منازلها
الرائعه
احذرن سنمر بكل اريحيه سواز مرتبطه بهذه
الجزيره ارتباطا
وثيقا اقدم لكم في هذه الصوره جدي
وجدت
جدي كان قائدا في الجيش وكان كذلك رئيس
البلديه في الجزيره لذلك انا فخوره بهما
جدا في خليج موريون توجد جزر سياحيه
بامتياز وجزر ذات ملكيه خاصه مثل الجزيره
التي يملكها برنار يذهب اليها عبر قارب
صغير فقط عند انتهاء ظاهره المد اذهب
اليها لست ساعات فقط في اليوم لا استطيع
فوق ذلك حتى لو كان الطقس جيدا وحين اعود
التزم كذلك فتره نفسها في اليوم ست ساعات
والا علي انتظار انتهاء ظاهره
المد تنتمي هذه الجزيره الى عائله بيرنار
منذ سبعه اجيال تبلغ مساحتها ثلاثه
هكتارات فقط صغيره جدا حيث تختفي شواطئها
تحت الامواج عند المد العادي وتصير هذه
القطعه من الارض معزوله عن بقيه العالم
يعيش بها برنار نصف العام برفقه زوجته
اقدم لكم
[موسيقى]
كثرين حياه بسيطه كح
وس هذا الكوخ القديم ليس به كهرباء ولا
ماء لذلك يقومون بجلب المياه معهم من
اليابسه لملئ هذا
الخزان هنا نغسل وجوهنا ونغسل الاواني
والصحون هذا هو المطبخ وهو الحمام
كذلك وتبريد يستعملان هذه لدينا الثلاجه
التي تعمل بالغاز والتي نضع فيها الطعام
الطازج واغلق على الفور بسبب الحراره نضع
بها كذلك شرابي والنبيذ والزبده ليس لديكم
مكان واسع الخيار صعب اذا علينا ان نختار
ماذا نضع الان وضعنا
النبي هذا المكان المطل على مياه الخليج
يعد بمثابه مملكه بالنسبه لهذين
الزوجين صباح الخير ايتها
الخرفان الا تشعران بالوحده قليلا احيانا
وسط هذه
الجزيره لا مع بعضنا دائما لا نشعر بها
هناك ما يكفي من الشعور الجميل او العمل
الذي لا نحس معه بالوحده او
العزله انظري الى اشعه الشمس في الافق في
جنته السريه يتمتع برنار وكاثرين باطلاله
خلابه على احواض المحار في الارخبيل
والمعروفه بمناجم الذهب في خليج موربي
يوجد في الخليج 1500 هكتار منها اصحاب
مزارع تربيه المحار يتناقلون هذا الشغف لا
بعد جيليك واحد منهم خصائص الخليج مناسبه
تماما لتربيه المحار سواء كان طقس سيئا او
جيدا في هذا الارخبيل المحمي من تيارات
المحيط الاطلسي القويه يملك بيغي ك
الامكنه المثاليه لاحتضان المحار وتربيته
والده من علمه بدء من سن العاشره انزل يا
بياخ حتى نتمكن من وضعها هنا من سيخلفه في
ذلك مضمون ابنه بي 13 سنه ضحى بشكل عمودي
بجانب ببعضها البعض علمني منذ كنت صغيرا
هذه المهنه تسير في دمي منذ كنت صغيرا
انزل الى هذه المياه ينغص منها هناك قليلا
كل سنه ينتج بييك 400 طن من المحر قسم
منها يوجه الى زبائن مطعم العائله الذي
تشرف عليه زوجته مارينا الخبيره في فتح
هذا
الكنز علينا ان نفتحها بشكل مستمر احيانا
افتح بين 2 و500 الى 3000 في
اليوم اقوم بادخال السكين في نهايتها هكذا
واقطع العصب الذي يربط
القشره تبدو العمليه بسيطه نعم تبدو
بسيطه داخل المطعم هناك ايضا من سيحمل
المشعل الفتاه
بولين رفقتي مع زوجي في العمل تشبهها كذلك
رفقه ولدي بير يكون في الانتاج بينما
ترافقه بولين في البيع وتحضير المحار وهذا
ما نقوم به حاليا ون حضره مع بعضنا البعض
شغف عائلي يلقى استحسانا لدى
الزبائن انه لذيذ
جدا انه منعش جدا نحن وسط مكان رائع مع
قليل من النبيذ والمحار ماذا نطلب اكثر من
ذلك شكرا
فيفي مع اسلوب حياه خاص ومناخ محلي
استثنائي وجزر صغيره جميله صنف خليج موربي
كم محميه طبيعيه في البلاد منذ
2014 اصبح البحر الصغير لمنطقه لا بغتان
كما يلقب حديقه طبيعيه
[موسيقى]
اقليميه